hot breath um do you think it took
people a while to
get your low energy style yeah
i had to because i followed godfrey he
was following god foreign and like all
them in new york
i learned that i had to like i can't
match their energy if i
i remember once i'm doing show roy
scoville and i remember i tried to match
rory scovel's
you know he's weird and loud and yelled
all this stuff
so roy is very easy to like like be like
i want to do that
because it seems very fun and i tried it
one night after him and i bombed
jay larson was there and he's like yeah
why are you trying to match his energy
and i was like you're right i shouldn't
i should've just done me
so you got to do what you do and so what
i learned to do a quick easy way to get
people into your rhythm
is you get your first joke or two is is
going to not work
but that's how you get them into like so
i learned that i needed them to hear my
voice
so i would always start very weird and
awkward i would always go on stage and
i still do it and i go on stage i'm like
all right here we go i hope this goes
good
maybe this is not going to go good i
don't know like i don't even really care
you're going to get laughs just for but
those are not important laughs
i'm just trying not to make my first
joke not get a laugh so i'm saying a
bunch of dumb stuff
to make them hear my voice get into my
rhythm
uh and then they go okay and then the
audience is like all right i know what
this guy does and then you get into your
first joke and now i've got them into
the way i talk like i i've always had to
learn how to get them into
my tone so just go on stage and whatever
you do
just say dumps you know be like oh all
right here we go this is i hope this
goes good whatever you're
you know right persona if you're you
know like a cocky persona you'd be like
this is gonna be the best part you got
you could yell that
it's just kind of throw away stuff so
the audience can then hear your voice
so it's not just a shock you know
you